if i were to go there to visit what
would be the singular barbecue spot i
would have to the giant i like is
actually it ain't even in memphis it's
in south haven it's called memphis
barbecue
you know south haven in mississippi but
it's like it's in mississippi yeah but
it's like right there about me if it's
like me if it's right there once you
cross a red light they got casinos in
mississippi right
do you like is that do that do you ever
just go party in mississippi go hit the
casino no
like uh
my so i got a sister to stay in south
haven that's the only time i used to go
out there then like
actually
i was just living in my friend's house
she like stay like he's bad like it's
kyle
what is kyle what's wood where's who is
right bad mississippi so like okay
instead of going to the stoves and
where's we
drive like if the 15 20 minutes and go
to mississippi that's how close
mississippi and memphis
hmm
super close
when i grew up i just thought
mississippi was like just everybody was
in the kkk because every
every racist movie that's ever existed
in the 90s was in mississippi there's
mississippi burning
time to kill mississippi for sure
yeah everybody say that on camera what
what did i say
i've watched enough
[ __ ] matthew mcconaughey movies to
know
but yeah like i never been like i went
to took to the casino one time and that
was when i turned
21. no i was already 21 actually it was
before i turned 22 and i just went
because i had
got some money did you win money no i
lost two hundred dollars in stock
i hate losing money like i could never
be a casino person oh yeah